les bons soirs à tous
se déplacer est il encore un besoin
essentiel de l'être humain
avant d'essayer de répondre à cette
question établissons entre nous quelques
faits que j'espère le plus objectif
possible
d'abord les transports coûtent cher
pensez à votre plein d'essence et si
ceux qui nous regardent dans le futur ne
savent pas ce que veut dire le plein
d'essence est une très bonne nouvelle
croyez moi les transports coûtent cher
donc et transport polluent car il
utilise encore aujourd'hui pour quelques
décennies est essentiellement des
énergies fossiles
et puis les transports en commun eux
sont extraordinairement subventionné
autrement dit le prix que vous ne payez
pas dans le billet vous le payez au
travers de vos impôts comme contribuable
ajoutons peut-être à cela deux éléments
d'abord les transports physiques sont
aujourd'hui concurrencée par les
nouveaux outils du numérique pensez au
télétravail et la visioconférence et
puis nous sommes tous
sujets du dérèglement climatique est
donc sommé à l'action
l'heure est à la sobriété de le
déplacement et certains préconisent même
d'aller un cran plus loin d'avoir par
exemple des cartes carbone individuel a
utilisés annuellement ou encore de
pouvoir bénéficier partout de
l'intégralité du monde tout en restant
chez soi c'est la promesse du metaverse
mais quand on parle de transformation
rapide et profonde beaucoup d esprit
raisonnable nous disait qu'il n'était
pas possible d'organiser ces
transformations sous peine de révolution
mondiale spontanée or nous vivons dans
un monde de rupture brutale
à nouveau pour ceux qui nous regardent
dans le futur en 2050
souvenez-vous qu'en 2020 nous avons
collectivement connu une crise celle du
co vide qui a conduit des centaines de
millions d'entre nous partout dans le
monde à être privé de déplacements
individuels et à rester chez soi pendant
de nombreuses semaines parfois de
nombreux mois
de la même façon en 2022 la russie a
mené une guerre à l'ukraine qui a
démontré partout en europe et dans le
monde à quel point les transports
étaient dépendants des énergies fossiles
et nous avons observé une montée des
prix tout à fait spectaculaire
et transport coûte donc cher ils
polluent des alternatives numériques
sont possibles et nous vivons un monde
de rupture brutale la question se pose
donc de savoir si nous pouvons si nous
devons organiser une réduction drastique
de le déplacement
pour y répondre nous
sommes renseignés de l'expérience du coc
vite j'en parlais à l'instant
et les empiète les études ont montré
qu'une des premières conséquences du
moindre déplacement quand ils aient subi
et pas choisi c'est un grand isolement
par ailleurs et est évidemment
l'être humain a besoin de se déplacer
physiquement mais c'est avant tout un
être social qui a besoin de se déplacer
pour socialiser pour se divertir pour
organiser la société les solidarité
entre les générations la paix
est donc cet être social cette dimension
est donc tout à fait importante et puis
l'effet démographique sont têtus il y
aura d'ici 2060 5 une population en
constante augmentation
des classes moyennes vont émerger par
centaines de millions en afrique en asie
c'est déjà le cas en amérique du sud et
les besoins de déplacement de ce fait
vont croître
ces sociétés c'est classe moyenne
émergente voulons en quelque sorte
bénéficient des mêmes libertés qu'ont
connu les sociétés occidentales pendant
40 ans ou depuis 40 ans
autrement dit et de façon très lucide
les besoins de transport partout dans le
monde vont augmenter dans les prochaines
années il ne s'agit donc pas de moins se
déplacer mais bien de mieux se déplacer
je vois ici une parenthèse pour les
bonnes âmes
la préservation de notre planète est
souvent présenté comme un altruisme un
humanisme c'est en vérité l'acte 0 du
raisonnement égoïste
nous avons besoin d'une planète en bonne
santé pour accommoder nos activités une
bonne action mais aussi nos turpitudes
certains l'ont juste compris avant
d'autres et on fait de l'écologie
le coeur de leur stratégie économique
penser aux panneaux solaires chinois à
tesla constructeur automobile
je ferme ici la parenthèse la transition
écologique et bien sûr une nécessité
mais elle est aussi une opportunité
au fond si nous sommes d'accord sur
cette analyse de quelles options
disposons nous collectivement
la première option est de revenir au
temps des petites cités où nous ne nous
déplacions que dans des rayons de
dizaines de kilomètres où nous
socialisons avec un environnement de 100
150 personnes
ce mode de vie répond bien sûr à
certaines aspirations communautaire mais
ils se désintéressent à nous besoin
universel en tant que population
mondiale
la deuxième option
consiste à organiser de façon globale et
autoritaire la réduction drastique de
nos déplacements ce qui poserait ici est
très con traitement entre nous des
questions
très pratiques faut-il se déplacer à
l'international une fois tous les trois
ans faut-il organiser les vacances pour
ceux qui ont la chance d'en prendre en
rayon d'une dizaine de km autour de chez
soi et je pourrais continuer à l'envi
vous avez compris
l'esprit de la question
système autoritaire nous l'avons connu
au xxème siècle il visait alors à
instaurer l'égalité et on a résulté
de façon assez globale un
appauvrissement collectif et une
privation des libertés individuelles
j'ajoute que pour qu'ils existent il
s'agirait aujourd'hui de s'organiser en
gouvernance mondiale qui convenons-en
ici est encore loin d'exister
il ya une 3e option que je pense juste
qui est celle d'une transformation
rapide profonde organisé démocratique de
la société et de la façon que nous avons
de nous déplacer
cela nécessite d'allier la sobriété nos
déplacements autrement dit se déplacer
quand nous en avons vraiment besoin
sobriété qui s'allierait avec
l'efficacité énergétique de nos modes de
transport autrement dit dépenser moins
d'énergie pour le même nombre de
kilomètres parcourus et puis bien sûr de
continuer à investir massivement dans la
science pour découvrir ou mieux
maîtriser mieux contrôler des
technologies qui sont encore aujourd'hui
non mature
et cette dimension
cette troisième proposition il nous
convient aujourd'hui de l'envisager dans
ses
acceptions les plus concrètes et donc de
poser un certain nombre de priorités
d'abord il faut agir là où finalement
les émissions sont les plus importantes
et vous le savez les émissions des
transports c'est à peu près 30% des
émissions produites en france et un peu
partout en europe et dans le monde et
parmi les émissions des transports 50%
des émissions sont produites par les
véhicules particuliers et véhicules
individuels il s'agit donc de continuer
la transformation des véhicules va aller
vers les véhicules électriques c'est la
révolution d'aujourd'hui et d'envisager
la révolution d'après celle du véhicule
à hydrogène qui s'organise là aussi dès
aujourd'hui
il s'agit ensuite partout où c'est
possible de développer les alternatifs
aux véhicules individuels les trains les
bus et bateau
et de le faire avec là aussi beaucoup de
lucidité parce que je les dis et
transports en commun coûte cher et
partout où ils sont développés coûte
cher à la collectivité et donc il s'agit
de regarder lucidement des sujets comme
la gratuité des transports qui parfois
conduire s il était complètement engagé
à précariser dans le long terme notre
capacité a été passer collectivement et
puis enfin et c'est peut-être le plus
important il s'agit de continuer
d'inventer de créer ce siècle qui s'est
ouvert il ya maintenant une petite
vingtaine d'années connaîtra de nouveaux
avions hypersonique est propre
le transport fluvial va révolutionner la
logistique urbaine les ports les
aéroports vont devenir des aubes
énergétique des carburants propres vont
être développée un peu partout et tout
ceci nécessitera évidemment beaucoup
d'énergie électrique décarbonés et la
deuxième partie de ce siècle connaîtra
l'avènement de la fusion nucléaire qui
nous permettra comme collectivité
humaine de bénéficier d'une quantité
quasi illimité d'énergie décarbonée
j'espère là aussi que ceux qui nous
regardent en 2050 ne me démentiront pas
n'en déplaise aux esprits chagrins
l'être humain
est fondamentalement et j'allais dire
anthropologiquement optimiste
parce qu'il est un être social se
déplacer est un besoin essentiel de
l'être humain
laon privé c'est la servir
et au fond dans cette petite aventure
peut être grande aventure humaine
il faut se poser la question de la place
que nous voulons collectivement y
prendre
il ya toujours ceux qui sont sceptiques
ou qui sont les tenants du statu quo
cela je propose de continuer à essayer
de les convaincre et à défaut de les
combattre
si nous ne sommes pas sceptique c'est
que nous sommes convaincus et de
convaincus nous devons devenir engagée
sur le plan
entreprenariale social humanitaire
associatif au delà des éco gestes
individuels du quotidien
et puis nous pouvons devenir des
pionniers
ceux qui vont inventer les nouvelles
technologies de demain les nouveaux
modes d'organisation et nouveau
modalités de financement ce qui
c'est créateur ses inventeurs qui
s'inscrivent dans un cadre démocratique
qui respecte les libertés individuelles
qui organise le bien-être collectif pour
le meilleur
mes chers amis
le monde idéal est celui que vous avez
apporté de rêve alors respectons le
engageons-nous merci m
[Applaudissements]